seventy-nine thousand eight hundred and
forty dollars the average salary of a
computer programmer in America average
meaning many can afford a big fancy
house or rent a closet in San Francisco
even the lowest paid ten percent make
more than the average American
programming is so well paid because it's
so in demand and so in demand because
it's growing so quickly in importance
but it's more than a trend surely it's
the inevitable direction of things right
say something big like programming is
the future and people conclude that fast
forward 20 years if you don't know how
to program well good luck getting a job
at McDonald's but as long as there are
jobs economic laws say people will
specialize and there's no reason to
think programming is any different a
valuable skill to learn absolutely and
more so every day in the way of reading
and writing not even close
not everyone should code and saying
otherwise may only harm those you intend
to help the biggest fans of everyone
should code are politicians and
technology companies and that's no
coincidence to a politician more of any
job that means more taxes more spending
more everything good and programming
jobs pay especially well so they're
especially loved but there's also
something unique about these jobs in
particular technology companies often
started by programmers have
international influence like no one else
if someone is going to pull the world's
financial and emotional levers and
unfortunately we know they are you as a
politician want them in your country he
who regulates the technology company
regulates the world America's power as
home to so many global technology giants
is hard to underestimate few companies
have so much financial and cultural
influence imagine America's reaction if
instead they were based in I don't know
say Russia people like President Obama
are so vocal about coding because they
understand is potential so does China
they've decided it's too high a price to
pay and for technology companies
everyone should code is everyone should
flood the market with the skills we need
but it's not all self-interest there's
also a dangerous mix of good
intentions and the dunning-kruger effect
[Music]
seeing trends it's easy to make a
prediction it won't be long before
nearly all jobs require programming and
the solution is to encourage an already
financially troubled generation to
pursue the high-paying safe job of
computer programming but a little bit of
foresight can be more dangerous than
none at all seeing the potential of
programming without knowing what it's
really like programmers do make a lot of
money but so do surgeons actually three
times as much and dentists and
psychologists and lawyers so why is
programming treated in a way surgery
isn't because we're told it's not just
another trade but an essential skill
like reading and writing and if it is
then it totally should be required in
every school but if not and I don't
think it is then it's just one
admittedly pretty good career path of
many could anyone perform surgery given
enough time and training yeah maybe but
people have different talents surgery
may be in high demand but we know it's
not for everyone
in fact specialization is good it's the
reason we have computers at all every
single one of us could be completely
self-reliant but you're probably not
going to be the best hunter cobbler cook
engineer and scientist in the world when
you have to do everything you can be
good at nothing so how about this you
get really good at farming
I'll make bricks and we can trade this
way we can both have really nice stuff
that's the basis for civilization and
you might say well both farmer and
Masons still need to read and write but
programming can't be such a skill it's
difficult enough that it just doesn't
make economic sense for everyone to
learn it unless or until robots take
over everything jobs need done more and
more will involve computers but it won't
be doctors and teachers programming them
because as long as programmers get
better at programming and teachers get
better at teaching by each sticking to
their crafts they will so as far as jobs
go it's so really good one but it is
just a job not a basic universal skill
a good teacher can take a complicated
topic deconstruct it and explain it in
easier terms to make accessible is
necessarily to simplify but it's really
easy to do what looks identical but
actually oversimplifies in fact that's
the challenge of youtube don't simplify
and you have a boring two-hour video
over simplify and you paint a misleading
picture in its enthusiasm to make
programming accessible
everyone should code does exactly that
tap-tap-tap that's programming
definitely not sitting at a desk for
long hours solving problems here's the
thing whether you've been to college or
have any programming experience you can
pay a company to teach you how to code
in 14 weeks and for not that much money
that should be a huge red flag if you
can become a developer in 14 weeks
either companies overpay for what's
really a simple job or there's actually
much more to it and of course there is
it's the difference between programming
and computer science the first you
really can learn in 14 weeks you can
read it in a book its memorizing what to
type to make a computer do a thing
that's what everyone should code teaches
but it claims the benefits of computer
science solving efficient creative
mathematical problems that's what
companies pay six-figure salaries for
and if that's your thing awesome
in fact I'm one of those people but many
maybe most wouldn't actually enjoy it
that doesn't mean you shouldn't teach
programming but it has to be honest it
can be accessible and inclusive but not
misleading stem is also cheers for the
money but that too attracts the wrong
people it would be awesome if teachers
were paid more but one benefit of what
we have is how it selects for people
passionate about the job not just after
a paycheck lots of people go into
computer science just for the money but
they may end up hating it and the irony
is when you sell people on an
unrealistic job supply Rises and
salaries fall because you might imagine
a huge team of people behind every tech
company but very few are actually
engineers when Instagram has 7 million
users it had four employees four as in
4.0 there will be more demand for
programming but not unlimited demand so
we might as well attract who's actually
interested
isn't everyone's cup of tea and adding
too much sugar will only make it extra
bitter when they find out what it's
really like
maybe programming isn't for everyone but
neither is history or music or art and
we all take those classes in school
surely there are other benefits to
learning programming there's no doubt
programming teaches skills like
problem-solving and creative thinking
but this puts the cart before the horse
if you're already sold on the importance
of programming it's easy to see
everything through that lens coding is a
way to understand our world and think
differently but if those are the skills
we care about let's find the best way to
teach them if we suddenly have 60
minutes of school to spare I'd suggest a
class on personal finance or critically
consuming media or speaking the class
were the biggest impact on my life was
debate and critical thinking is much
needed coding classes should be
available for those interested but not
as a requirement because everyone learns
differently and at a different pace and
likes different things I know my high
school didn't teach all the subjects I
wanted to learn but that's what's so
great about Skillshare it's an online
learning community for you maybe you're
interested in animation in which case
you can learn from the Masters
themselves the KERS Gazette team they
give you graphics to work with so you
can download them follow along and make
a fantastic video so if you want to make
a video like this one or even better
Skillshare is a great way to get a head
start if you are interested in
programming or want to find out if you
are they have classes that can ease you
into it but it's the real deal that will
help you really understand a computer
science with classes like this one which
teach you all the big concepts behind
computing you can also ask questions
download content and submit your work
but you're not locked into structured
classes and you don't have to pay per
class so you're free to learn exactly
what you want how much you want and by
who you want there are a ton of classes
on pretty much any topic so you can pick
which one works best for you with an
annual subscription Skillshare is less
than ten dollars a month or you can just
try it out the first 500 people to use
the link in the description will get
their first two months for free and risk
free thanks to skill share and to
everyone who supports the channel by
using the link
you
[Music]